some call it a home run bringing the
Oakland A's and a new baseball stadium
to Las Vegas thank you for joining us
here at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Brian Loftus now before that becomes a
reality there's a tight deadline to get
half a billion dollars for it at a local
union he's left wondering if the people
working there will be able to unionize 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthey joins us
live near the land intended to house the
stadium near Tropicana and Dean Martin
with details Ryan
yeah Kirsten Brian the entire Project's
estimated at 1.5 billion dollars all on
49 acres some of it just behind me here
near Dean Martin and Tropicana but up to
a third of that total price tag the A's
want Public Funding for legislators are
questioning when they're going to ask
for that while union leaders say the
team needs to step up to the plate
none of this is simple none of it is
easy Jeremy Aguero is principal analyst
for Applied analysis The Firm hired to
help the A's craft a deal this
transaction is in many ways less
complicated than others that we've
worked through before and he comes with
experience
he also helped to bring a legion stadium
and the finances for it much of the
groundwork then he says is making a
potential Bill easier to craft but this
one is different and that it attempts to
capture all of the taxes created by the
stadium and reinvest them back into the
stadium that does not exist in the state
of Nevada today and so it would require
the legislature to do that a special tax
District to get up to 500 million
dollars but State Assembly speaker Steve
Yeager told the Nevada independent on
Wednesday a bill to create this has not
yet been presented and the clock's
ticking The Proposal needs to be
submitted before the current legislative
session ends on June 5th I don't want to
suggest you that time is infinite but I
also believe that as those conversations
continue and as deal points get refined
that that legislation can come together
in a reasonable way end of the day these
are part-time jobs and while the
legislature Waits on that The Culinary
Union which represents 60 thousand and
Resort and Stadium workers in Nevada
says the A's won't confirm if the
workers there will be able to unionize
secretary treasurer Ted Papa George says
they've been in Communications for over
a year the governor needs to understand
that too and does the legislature
because otherwise the voters will have
their final say
now there is also the possibility this
goes past the legislative session the
governor would then need to call a
special session on this and for context
when Allegiant stadium was going through
this process in 2016 it had its own
special session and it took just four
days reporting live near Dean Martin and
Tropicana Ryan Matthey a news now
representatives for the Oakland A's did
not return 8 News now's multiple
requests for comment today additionally
representatives for assembly leader
Jaeger directed us to the Nevada
independent article for comment you